happy birthday to you happy birthday to
you happy birthday dear de babe I know
I'm like a week late happy birthday do
you it's me the breaker of the eye
welcome to genius brain matter people my
name is Joe Jitsu Kawa and I'm David so
and we have brains of genius so we
started this podcast to do talking to do
the talking man this is a podcast about
nothing and everything you know I think
a lot of people are saying or what or
they're asking kind of generally well
what's the general topics of this
podcast I don't like general topics of
anything I just do mean like what do we
always talk about yeah what's the main
thing I don't [ __ ] know even
off-camera like we talked for hours dude
this is our this is our off-camera
conversations you know it's interesting
because when I was doing you know when
we do JK news yeah a lot of it's the the
point of JK needs to be entertaining as
possible right because these are short
excerpts and we have these flash
articles and ideas so sometimes why'd
you guys elaborate well it's a [ __ ]
ten minute video yeah like people don't
understand how it works behind the
scenes yeah so for I mean it's so easy
right it's like when you're watching
sports right like it's so easy go I just
you shoulda [ __ ] made the basket man
what the [ __ ] yeah that's what's
happening really the comment sections
all bunch of audience people you know
like it's it's like oh you should have
done it this way all why didn't you tell
it that way it's better it's so funny
when I remember we uh we should get
[ __ ] Heat
funny got a hot topic stuff I four or
five days late yeah people would be bet
they're like yo that was way late you
guys are so late yeah but then we
started putting it out earlier they're
like well you don't have all the
information well of course not because
you asked for it early yeah that's why
we used to put it out late yeah it's so
so we would get the information right
but then when we got the information
wrong because what happens is these
keyboards are so funny cuz they would be
like well if you guys did your research
you would know that it was because it
you only found out after the fact why do
they all sound like disapproving Asia
they're channeling their inner Asian
parent and chip how could you be an
aging parent when you watch just kidding
use you son of a [ __ ] no I think it's
just I used to get pissed off about it
but it just tells me that they care a
lot you know and it's just uninformed
comments yeah just making comments cuz
they don't know ya if they knew then
they'll be like oh [ __ ] okay yeah like I
think the right [ __ ] there's the right
[ __ ] like I I wrote back to somebody and
I [ __ ] up my new year's goal my new
year's goal was to only write positive
comments and then I'd not do that I
cannot do it it's like it's like an itch
I have to scratch it you have to be you
have to fight I have to bet and it's not
even because like I feel vindicated it's
more like damn I have a really good
insult for this person yeah it sucks I
can't write it yeah because you love
roasting yeah yeah so it's like ah
because like it just makes me so mad and
I never roast people who who wrote me
really well yeah that's just funny as it
is but for some people who write
something that's clearly not funny it's
like I gotta make fun of this person
because it's so bad dude yeah I had this
ajusshi like right on my channel he goes
oh you know I don't understand why you
always don't like a Korean people and
why you say why you why you so always
talk down about our people I've never
heard you talk down about Koreans never
if anything I mean your joke yeah but
maybe something's being lost in
translation oh for sure he goes and then
he writes this whole fake conversation
he goes I imagine your mommy and daddy
say this they go oh how come my son
crushed so much and then they go I'm not
a proud of him at all he [ __ ] wrote
something to that line where he wrote a
fake between me and my fear on a script
yeah he put a lot of thought into this
[ __ ] I just laughed out loud
extra lol ha ha ha ha ha I couldn't stop
[ __ ] laughing and I remember I was
taking a [ __ ] while I was reading this
comment oh my god I just kept writing
back and forth this guy because I was
like this guy's a [ __ ] lunatic
because I looked on his YouTube channel
and on his YouTube channel it's him it
is office going so these are my office
uh today I happen to work nobody here
because I'm hard
and only one in the office for you yeah
and he was like talking to me a Bahama
disgrace to Koreans how I how I miss how
I'm like I he basically was saying that
me putting out my content is a stain in
the Korean culture made Koreans look bad
and four-time Korean American
[ __ ] I'm two sides to the coin
homie yeah American and Korean
[ __ ] it's the American side that
made it ain't it it's like my American
side my opinionated side it's so funny
he thinks you're the representative of
all of Korea and he's like he has to be
like 40 something years old if it
doesn't look bad it's like not dude your
existence is actually making us look bad
dude that's what's so funny when adults
make fun of like people our age younger
they go oh all you kids do is sit around
and just do nothing on the internet I'm
like you do the same [ __ ] don't [ __ ]
lie you piece of [ __ ] especially
Facebook all these middle-aged people
talking about like all kids they just
[ __ ] have nothing good to say they're
always drama and it's like you're the
worst at least like you [ __ ] 50-plus
year olds on on Facebook because the sad
thing is like kids on Facebook at least
half of them are trolls think they're
doing it yeah they're [ __ ] around
there's why they're trying to get a
reaction from you but a hundred percent
of all people completely believe
everything that you say they don't get
the Internet they don't they don't
understand the internet at all they
don't understand what trolls are and
they just argue all day they're just
arguing about Trump or some [ __ ] all day
it's like shut the dam and you think
we're petty it's like they write um I
like it when old people they do the old
they start using memes yeah people are
not funny at all
but they're trying to see what young
people are doing and they go oh they're
making this political commentary about
some [ __ ] that I like so I'm gonna make
it my own mean yeah and then it's the
most unfunny [ __ ] political meme I've
ever seen in my life but they're dying
laughing on the other side did you see
this this is hilarious I like it when
they spread [ __ ] fake knees this one
I saw that was going around
remember when Pokemon go was coming out
like this and the fake news was like oh
Japan is using Pokemon go to
you know basically like tap into
everybody's phones and GPS so they can
like like spy on Americans yeah and it's
like Japan in America has been like
allies for over 40 years a long time
there's like multiple American military
bases in Japan like yeah okinawa
yokohama all that stuff it is like
that's to me that's like saying britain
is spying on [ __ ] US citizens
yo that's like that [ __ ] were who was
that who was the guy that he was well he
was put on for saying the Sandy Hook was
Alex Jones Alex Jones batshit crazy yes
and I didn't realize how number one i
i'm not i wasn't that big into
conspiracy stuff fell not that not now
not because it doesn't interest me it's
just there's so much information to read
oh I love conspiracies yeah I I can't
process all of it but you know just
looking into Alex Jones and kind of
reading what he was about like he's he's
insane like he's it's a character he's
kind of like crazy yeah I mean there is
a little bit to it but it's so if you
see his old stuff yeah like he was more
chill but then when he started ranting
in his Alex Jones character that's like
if I became uncle chin because Martin
was like so popular yeah and then like I
so much time being uncle chin that that
became me that's what it feels like
right because it's like it's almost like
he doesn't know how to turn it off
because when I started looking into Alex
Jones this cousin ain't kept popping up
it was because he had an interview with
Joe Rogan yeah and I just I was like do
my stop yelling dude they're homies oh
like they you know they [ __ ] did a
sit together like they hung out but Joe
Rogan says is all the time like he's my
friend but he's batshit crazy his he
sounds like he just eats screws and nuts
and you know the [ __ ] though
the bakers the world bakers you need you
think you know her - Joe you're smarter
than this you know I'm like but the
[ __ ] funny thing is there's a lot of
people that like die by him they believe
him
like for me this has always been
entertainment I love conspiracy because
I love like how the human mind can have
so much imagination but also there's
some truth to conspiracy because you
should never completely trust anything
there's been some conspiracy theories
that have been proven right right like
yeah there's like a list of them yeah
there's a list of them but there's also
like some that's just [ __ ] bogus -
but it's interesting you know but for me
it's always like oh look at things you
know in a skeptical way but the problem
with conspiracy and the people that are
too much into it is they believe it
first and then they try to prove that
right all the time even the evidence is
like they don't give up so like
yesterday I was watching this Flat Earth
documentary on Netflix
that's that oh yeah then they basically
bring like flat earthers and then they
bring like scientists and in a interview
them separately and you know they have a
bunch of people from Cal Tech and all
that so like in the flat earth community
is actually growing like it's getting
bigger and bigger and all right there's
a lot of people that believe it that the
the earth is flat yeah oh [ __ ] I thought
that was just more like for people were
doing it for fun no it it's there but it
also made me realize like so you know
how like like we enjoy making kind of
like roasting people making them feel
stupid yeah because obviously they're so
[ __ ] stupid that it's fun to [ __ ]
with them right yeah but what I real
after watching this documentary I was
like well okay like you know what I
really want to do is help people it
doesn't help them it just alienates them
and then basically at the end of the
documentary the scientists were saying
this like I think the problem is not
coming from the flat earthers it's
coming from us like you know like us
scientists like it's hard not to look at
people
and and kind of be condescending and
kind of look down on them like they're
dumb or crazy or whatever but he's like
we got to look at it in a way where it's
like hey this guy is a potential
scientist like he just didn't go through
the same process so they don't have the
tools in their head to understand what
is real science and and how do you how
do you have a you know how do you go
through the process how do you have with
hypotheses and how do you test your
hypothesis and then like once you have
your theory how do you give it to a
bunch of people that can test it because
conspiracies and flat earth and things
like that it's it works the opposite way
you have a hunch or whatever it is and
then you you have what you kind of
cherry-pick the evidence that just
conveniently works with your conspiracy
and then you don't want to believe any
opposing thing you could write it off
and say oh well you know for example one
of the flatter theories is like oh well
you know there's a huge government
conspiracy there's a world government
that that infiltrated all the schools
and then like you know so so the
information is it's controlled and like
when you look at the Google Earth and
whatever like you know people go up and
in they Photoshop it and there's just
all these reasons right yeah so to me
the difference is like one is a religion
and the other is more like a constant
test like science is a Content constant
test it's like you keep they say Oh
science keeps changing so they're never
right but it's like in reality that is
what science is exactly you keep testing
it until you get you get it right so
even if there is a solid theory for the
moment there might be more technology
that comes out and then we test that
theory and we realize oh we didn't have
the technology to measure this correctly
yeah yeah but then overall when I was
looking at this whole situation I was
like okay like so in this case the
scientists are kind of [ __ ] up because
they laugh at the flat earthers they
alienate them
and when I was watching how the Flat
Earth community is growing there's a lot
of people that just feel lonely and in
like when they get into this conspiracy
like they want to talk to their friends
and family and then they get made fun of
and then like you know they put so much
heart and they care so much about this
like newfound knowledge that of course
no one's I like oh really tell me more
about the Flat Earth they're just gonna
be like shut the [ __ ] up you crazy ass
yeah and then they start losing friends
cuz they're like oh well you don't care
about me cuz you don't care what about
what's important to me yeah and then
they find this Flat Earth community that
everyone yeah and then they build new
friends and they build new love and then
there's this common interest so then
because there's a community they can't
deny that it actually doesn't exist
because if they find out if the world
was round then what's bringing them
together so now they're stuck it's like
a cult like that's how cults form and
religions and all that stuff that's so
interesting because so for them there
they're found belief seemingly seems to
be not so much in the theory itself but
how if this this theory being around an
existing gives them meaning to their
life I think that's how a lot of things
happen like like think about activism
yeah right like when you and a bunch of
like-minded people get together and they
fight for a cause right and let's say
the cause is solved and you keep
fighting for what do you do what do you
do now you got to find another thing to
fight for together it's always fight
fight fight instead of like okay like we
got what we wanted now let's figure out
a way to live in this new life but then
you know that's why you got these angry
groups that are just constantly fighting
for something because that's what brings
them together it seems very the flatter
thing is almost is very much like
religion then right yeah I think so I
think most things groups that people
form I think it's very similar to
religion or cult or whatever you want to
call it because it's very because it
seems like flat earth that that's that's
definitely the reason why I like flat
earth and you know people who obviously
know that the world is round they need
me tend to clash be
as one is based by faith and one is
based by facts yeah so when a scientist
comes up and they says they say okay
well here are the reasons why this isn't
true lotta that like I say 80% of the
stuff that's a that's brought out a
flatters person in wall they want to
dress it no yeah they'll they'll go over
it or they'll mention some other fact
trying to debunk something that wasn't
even addressed yeah and so that's where
a scientist whose whole career is but he
stopped fax yeah it comes angry and
frustrated it's like what the [ __ ] are
you saying because they're not speaking
the same language yeah because the way
that these flattered scientists were
like talking about it is like well
they're in the documentary right they're
doing experiments that are debunking
their own theory yeah like oh the the if
the earth was round and when we like
point of light there should be like you
know like something in the middle I mean
they're talking about this and if it
fails they go oh well but there's like a
lot more other evidence is just didn't
work in there but that's not how science
works you know if there's one thing that
disproves it then it's one is enough to
go we got a reit we got to look at this
differently yeah but there are a lot of
fanatics in science too like out there
there's you know like I think it's just
human nature because like they do say in
in in academic science like they're so
kind of set in their ways that they
can't think outside the box to challenge
themselves yeah
so within science there's always like
revolutionary Minds right that come in
and and then they've disrupted but they
still use the scientific method yeah
which is something that I think people
outside of it don't use mmm so for me
like I like conspiracies because you
never know I like the unknown but I
don't believe it unless it's proven yeah
but to me I entertain it because it's
fun it's it's really interesting to see
where the mind can go and how much
investigation people do I think that's
what I like about science though is the
fact that even though something as of
right now is shown and proven as fact it
doesn't mean that it can't change later
yeah because science also doesn't turn a
blind eye to new facts right so
what was it which which planet was out
there that they said that was for sure a
planet but down to star I think it's
Pluto sunny oh right yeah so just
because it's been like that for a long
time yeah isn't gonna be a scientist
that's going to refute that after
there's new evidence stating that it's
not yeah so that's what I really like
about science it's it's it's still a
methodology to figure out truth
constantly yeah so the the the truth
that is there right now doesn't mean
it's going to be like that forever if
there's new evidence debunking it and
nobody will argue that yeah if it's
undeniable and yes right I mean
obviously like people will still say you
know Pluto's a planet to me yeah but if
there's facts to say otherwise the
scientific community won't argue that
right and that's what happens with
climate change mm-hmm this people are
upset about climate change because
people are taking anecdotal evidence
about what they experiencing like or
still cold here yeah you know and
they're confusing weather with climate
change in science yeah because they can
observe it and it's easier to yeah but I
mean that's just human nature like I
always say like we're no different from
our primitive ancestors we just got a
we're just like monkeys with technology
now yeah but if you think about you
still every human still has to evolve to
to the present day meaning like when
you're a child right you're like you're
literally like like a primitive creature
mmm and then you have to develop in
different stages and I think every human
goes to like the Stone Age you know the
Bronze Age the Golden Age the
Renaissance like your mind right yeah
but a lot of people get stuck in
different zones like we have some
complete brute you know like like just
just caveman kind of human being still
and then you have like super alien level
human beings that are just like out of
this world like Stephen Hawking like
some some total genius guys yeah and we
all it's I think like we can't look at
them as like you're beneath or above but
I do believe like there's different
levels of consciousness and different
different levels of people's like mental
abilities mmm yeah I mean like how can
you deny that right like like there's a
let ik people that's just out of this
world that's way better than the average
human being what that happens in the
mind - yeah you know I always found it
interesting when I think a lot of
conspiracy theorists they hold on to the
fact those there are cases where
conspiracies were proven right yeah and
that stuff is like a huge beacon of hope
right now because prior to people saying
that those people were crazy they were
actually proven right I wish I could
remember the the few the few that well
there's one here in LA which was proven
right and you know if you've noticed
everywhere it's like oh this is so
inefficient we should have public
transportation yeah so when the car
industry was growing they had a vision
for LA being like a bunch of roads and
every person have a car and so back in
back in like I don't know like the 1920s
or some [ __ ] like that
they had train tracks all over downtown
LA like oh if you listen to old folks
they go like I used to spend ten cents
and I can go from downtown to Santa
Monica like there was a train system
there was all that right the car
companies they built fake train and
trolley companies to buy up all of those
railways and all that just to just to
take them off so then then they can all
get together and start selling cars and
now LA is dependent on cars and there
were people at the time that we're
saying this is happening this is a
conspiracy no one they laughed at them
they didn't believe them but then like
that's what not true yeah and I think
walking crazy there's a lot of
conspiracies that have some truth to it
like there's something fishy going on
but it's difficult to prove until later
do that so [ __ ] insane I hate I
always wanted the public transportation
here to be better because I if it was
decent and I think there's enough people
here in the city where they will work
perfectly fine I would use it
consistently but there is no so I when I
used to live in South Pass I tried using
the the public transportation system
right and it sucks because number one
it's [ __ ] filthy
yeah dirty as a homeless man taking a
dump everybody cholos fighting it's it's
so crazy because um like the first time
that we used it Maryland I will reuse it
together just in the first the trolley
car that we were in there was a homeless
man but that wasn't the problem it's
just that he smelled really bad yeah it
was to the point where everybody had to
leave go to the other side yeah you
don't know not to him I mean the
homeless do but it's just like people
having to deal with that type of stuff
and there's no really like regulated and
controlled system is not reliable it
doesn't go to a lot of places yeah and
it just it takes forever so it [ __ ]
sucks it does you know I'm car companies
for that stupid says a [ __ ] that's how
they got ball and I don't even want to
buy car a car so I'm like looking at
cars right now just because I had the
Honda Element but I'm like I want
something more gas efficient yeah but I
hate driving so much I don't want to go
to the process of buying a new car I
like driving I don't like being in
traffic yeah that's the thing right yeah
I love long road trips I love yeah so
I'm just sitting there just thinking
like okay if I buy this new car it's
like what the [ __ ] am I where am I going
with this you know so I just like I
would like something a little more gas
efficient and the reason why I want that
you so I could say for some money yeah
so but other than that it's just just
having to the thought of me being in
traffic bothers me right yeah pisses me
off because it makes me it takes like
even today like just us I live on
average away from here what let's say
like 10 minutes no track yeah it took me
[ __ ] 25 minutes either like just
because one little mistake
mm-hm exit and it was like yes always
something in LA yeah yeah but I mean
that's where I think a lot of
conspiracies it's like motive right that
that's why I'm into it
it's like it's like a process of
elimination
like what is it most likely like is it a
world government probably not what I've
noticed is a lot of things are rooted to
money mmm it's rooted to somebody's gain
and in like so you know you can so for
example JFK right til this day it's not
solved no one knows why he was killed
why he was you know assassinated or
anything like really there's theories
yeah like there's there's
where he angered the mob because like
his family ran booze back in a day the
the Kennedy family got rich running
illegal liquor and they had a lot of
ties to the mob and the mob and the
unions helped him get elected but once
he got elected his brother was the head
of the FBI and they started cracking
down on mob so they basically backstab
him oh one of those yeah so so one of it
was like the mob was very powerful that
back then and so one of the conspiracy
is yeah they turned around and shot him
another one is he was about to expose
government secrets and he made this
speech and and talking about I think it
was a new world order or some [ __ ] like
that and then so they said that the
Illuminati got him and another one was
[ __ ] her so many another one was he
was planning to bring the gold standard
back so like that means like um our
dollar is backed by gold that yeah our
dollar used to reflect like like gold
back in a day but now it's just uh it's
a trust it's it's yeah it's based on
debt and and it's you know all that
stuff so they were saying like the
Federal Reserve or that banking system
came around and killed them but there's
like oh those are the ones that I I kind
of like they're more realistic there's
other ones where it's like oh he was
gonna expose that aliens control the
government and things like that those
are a little bit more far-fetched to me
but the moment but I think the
conspiracies that I like are always
linked to it's a little bit more
grounded like it seems plot like that
like this can happen when so was there
anything during like his presidency that
made people dislike him like for example
like if let's say you know you know god
forbid I'm not saying this should happen
but you know let's say the Trump
somebody attempted to assassinate a mean
there's not much motive to see why why
not because right because of all of the
the hate rhetoric that's going around
him yeah so but for John F Kennedy there
wasn't anything like that I don't know I
mean I wasn't a part of that era yeah I
just hear like just
I just read good things like now he was
one of the most beloved presidents and
and he he did a lot of things like
social things and he made a lot of
changes but I don't know I think the
people that he did piss off was like the
mob or like the people that have power
yeah so that's where a lot of the
conspiracies kind of like come out yeah
it's so weird because um you read about
all these like assassinations and the
way I think about what the house shitty
was your [ __ ] security dude I know
right I feel like it's damn near
impossible oh that's another one too
because the CIA or the FBI it was an
inside job so that's why his security
was shitty that day yeah I mean there's
so many conspiracies man you can never
tell but sometimes I like to go off the
deep end yeah and and like there's one
about like the moon being a satellite
what yeah it's like a alien like like
satellite it's in it's uh it's basically
like observing humanity that's like me
in like Scientology like Scientology is
like one of those things is III there's
no [ __ ] way I'm gonna believe it but
if if what they're saying is true that'd
be pretty [ __ ] dope you know okay no
thing the super you notice oh yeah the
whole superpower stuff I'm like damn
dude if if I ever wanted something to be
real yeah well I had to be [ __ ] real
I think it's dope like it's so unique
yeah you know like where are our worst
we're trapped Souls and we're unhappy
and we need to like unlock all this [ __ ]
and then like there's a special
superhero Xenu or whatever I'm surprised
[ __ ] Scientology hasn't like tapped
in the crack and saying like crack crack
is something that was brought from Zeno
because you [ __ ] I can do
backflips land on their face and they
walk up like nothing happened
I met someone that's um that group in
the Church of Scientology she's a stunt
woman she grew up in Hollywood
her parents were like deep and she says
she has a family member that was a part
of like their elite C group or whatever
I forgot what it was called but she says
like on the surface when you're at the
bottom level it just it's like a
community thing it's not that weird but
her mom
actually paid like hundreds of thousands
of dollars to be like very high up there
but she's like the closer you are to the
top is where the more the brainwashing
happens but in the very early like it's
just like you go there and then it's
like community you [ __ ] do acting
classes or you know you just go through
for your therapy though the weird thing
was when I watch that that that very
popular docu-series about the
Scientology thing was I felt bad for all
these people who went through all these
stages donated all this money yeah
finally reached the top and they go
that's it yeah and there that's what
happened to her mom her mom was like she
says I still don't feel better and I
spent so much money and then she went to
the top and she's like that's it and
then she started questioning yeah and
then she left but her aunt or someone
that went deep in like they actually
live in the compound and like they don't
talk to the family no more and I'm like
whoa that's [ __ ] crazy but she says
when she was a kid and growing up and
all that stuff like for her um it was
just like daycare and playing and and
she says like when she became a teen and
a little bit older like you just go
there to get cleared or whatever like
you just go in and talk and she's like
it's not that crazy but it can be when
you donate more and you level up but
she's like it's more about the money
than it is about the brainwashing do
cults are so interesting because I've
they definitely target a very specific
type of human being yeah right somebody
who I feel like it's people who are down
and out and they're looking for answers
and they really would just take any
puzzle piece that will fit into their
lives yeah and just gives them some type
of meaning that's why I [ __ ] science
and skepticism and [ __ ] is so good mmm
you know like if you don't have these
tools in your mind like being a skeptic
doesn't mean that you're in denial yeah
it's kind of like prove me right like I
can be proven right I'm open to it but
there's a lot of evidence that tells me
that I shouldn't believe this yeah so I
think there's a difference between that
and someone in denial or
that's just being negative someone
that's just being negative is just like
they completely ride at all I'm so
surprised he dropped out of high school
I feel I feel like the school system
failed you did I I didn't apply myself
but at the same time like I went to
college yeah but I think a lot of my
learning happened what I I think what I
loved about college is I learned how to
learn mmm and and I think my teachers
for that because like my professors knew
like when I went to a lower income
university or college East LA college
right
they knew what type of mentality we had
and they knew the right words to say to
get us out of there like I had a
sociology teacher she went to Harvard
she grew up in the ghetto Mexican lady
she was like one of the only few Latinas
during her time I mean she was like I
want to go back to East LA the SUV and I
want to help people elevate their heads
from where they're at and then all of us
were just sitting there like were ya
that's how the world is you know like we
didn't really know that [ __ ] exists and
in so like I think it's been a lifelong
battle to understand the difference
between like like anecdotal or or fact
or these different things that people
throw around but they don't know what
they mean you know like like for example
like our Asian parents are like this
right like for them if they heard it
from a friend if they read it in a
newspaper if they read it in a book
watch it on TV it's all fact yeah
there's no difference between like oh
you know this person spent 20 years and
as a physicist and understands like you
know gravity and all that when they when
they go to the Eastern medicine doctor
they go to the traditional doctor it has
the same weight yeah and that's what
[ __ ] with people's minds like that's
what makes them unintelligent or
actually they don't have the right tools
to make the best decision
because they don't know how to sort out
through the [ __ ] you know it's like
hey this guy he spent 20 years studying
acupuncture and he told me if I massage
my ballsack
like I'll cure my cancer yeah
they see hey this guy went to school for
20 years - at the [ __ ] at the [ __ ]
meditation factory or whatever what's
that
that's how is that different from this
doctor in his MD yeah yeah but that it's
just going back to the scientific method
right like yeah yeah that's how we try
to figure out that's what got us out of
the medieval [ __ ] yeah that's what
you know even when people say to they go
they'll ask me sometimes you know do you
regret going to college or trying to go
through the traditional method of
education and stuff like that I don't
think I regret it because it did it did
help give me perspective yeah and I and
I found out what I wanted through going
through that system and I think that
everybody should experience it up to a
certain extent yeah but you shouldn't
close yourself off to just that type of
education and I think that's where
people kind of get messed up a lot they
go okay well people equate the
university that they went to and where
they attended and the grades that they
got to being a smart human being yeah
and that's not the case because you know
how I explained it is this I'll go have
you have you ever been to a restaurant
where you hated the food and they go
yeah of course well there you go that
person also went to culinary school
doesn't he's a great chef yeah
absolutely not his food is trash right
yeah so if that's the same case for like
a traditional education just because you
went to a university doesn't mean that
everybody coming out of that school is
an intelligent person yeah sure
same concept so I think a lot of people
do close themselves off to to learning
more and that's that's where we go into
the concept of you know a lot of people
who are look smart but they're not very
street smart so they can they can take
this information they can go to class
somebody could say hey this is what you
do read the syllabus and you'll get this
great but then you tell them hey
something happened here can you solve
this problem they're [ __ ] brain fries
out well I think is because one
memorizes and in the other understands
yeah so when you understand material you
don't need to memorize it yeah yeah yeah
for most of our lives we're taught to
memorize yeah just what are these words
I don't know it kind of in context
like feels like this so a lot of people
use the wrong words yeah they just but
they just oh it sounds like this so I
mean yeah this is what I'm told to do so
I'm just gonna remember this sentence
and I'm gonna say this sentence 50 times
until I remember it and then when I take
the test I'm gonna write this sentence
down yeah but they don't know what it
means and I think that's a lot of people
that go through the school system right
it's like they try to it's human nature
to try to do the least amount of work to
get the biggest amount of gains yeah so
it's easier to memorize things and then
write it down and then get and get it
try to get an A mmm versus like
understanding a concept like I think
that's a lot harder yeah I mean that was
it's so funny because I'm only saying
this because I actually have a tendency
to be the person who follows
instructions and then tends to [ __ ] up a
lot so I've been trying to rewire that
and learn how to solve problems instead
which I have been getting better at but
just like in on a small level to like
for example I just live with my with my
roommate ray yeah ray is the type of
human being when something happens
he's gonna [ __ ] fix it and he'll
figure out how I'm gonna beg somebody to
do it for me so what like I kid you not
when something happens in the house I
would you scream ray and then he'll come
down here look at he goes hmm touches it
[ __ ] it around and he fixes it like
that's dope and I look at it I'm like
how do you [ __ ] do that yeah how do
you look at something and solve it like
that there's no instructions to this
year and he just does it that's how
Vince is - oh this stupid son of a [ __ ]
I hate him I love him so he's also the
guy when something happens he fixes it
because his number one his grandfather
was was like a carpenter a World Water
so he he just knows how to fix his Vince
has been fixing Roos and he's very
hands-on so I got this table and I
didn't want to I didn't want to make it
just because I knew was gonna take me
forever I started reading the
instructions to my business opens up the
box by the time I finished one chair he
built the table and the other chairs Wow
he just looked at it he goes yeah I know
how this works I mean I had a look at
the instructions and I was stuck on this
one instructional part that didn't fit
is because the instruction was actually
wrong and it told me to put the thing in
the other way this Vince being a guy who
doesn't need that he looks at something
says this doesn't work
I don't need to listen to this because
it's wrong and I'll fix it but for me I
was so fixated on what this piece of
paper was telling me I couldn't move
past it I'm so stupid you know and I
wish I didn't have it and that's what
ray does to Ray looks at information
that's given and he also questions it
and says hey this could possibly be
wrong let me see what the solution is
and sometimes I do have that too but I
do still do have that tendency of just
following what the instructions say damn
which isn't a problem but sometimes when
things don't work you have you do have
to learn how to problem-solve yeah and I
don't really have that it could just be
that have you heard of I think it's
called a five intelligence or some [ __ ]
like that there's like so like so for
example like it's it's like the saying
where it's like if you judge a fish by
how fast it could climb a tree then
you're you're the [ __ ] or whatever you
hear that or it's like of course the
monkeys gonna win right yeah so like but
if you judge a fish on how fast it could
swim it's gonna beat the monkey yeah so
it's like everyone has their kind of
niche right so like that is like spatial
intelligence some people are good with
that or like some people are emotionally
intelligent or socially intelligent or
like whatever and then there's a whole
list of it but mmm it might be that like
you don't spend time doing puzzles and
like you know building so you're just
new at it you know it's not like your
dumb ass it sucks because that's that's
just past the skill that I really want
because I will love naked and afraid oh
yeah i watch that show I realize how
much I wouldn't survive there's so much
like I think it's like a human innate
like there's such a weird attraction to
just building yeah it's like [ __ ] dude I
could watch it build all day cuz they're
even in that show you start to realize
who really has a knack and a skill for
something yeah so there's like episodes
where you see people in a similar
environment but it's a different episode
but you see people build these things
like I saw this guy he built his wrath
it was the shittiest looking thing I've
ever seen in my life
it was just like struck and that's the
that's the route that I would
I think there was another up for
somewhere another guy was creating a
raft yeah and it looked like something
you could buy off a catalog like it was
so crazy like he built a chair on the
raft yeah and then a rudder that you
could like steer in it and I'm like how
the [ __ ] did you make that from these
trees in like two weeks that makes no
sense
like I would the other guy I kid you not
decide his you want his wrath was it was
two logs that were strung together by
pine and he just laid on it literally
created a raft with eight armchair damn
well I bet you people say that [ __ ]
about your cooking
oh maybe right so it's like if you were
in negative afraid you'll be the guy
that like I'll catch the meerkat and you
cook the meal I definitely need somebody
to help me get to that point yeah cuz I
look at what they do and I'm like damn
they definitely understand how to use
everything in their environment and make
the most out of it yeah I would look to
them to do that and I would try to see
where I was fit uh you know because I I
don't have that type of leadership in
that scenario that's not something that
would be great at you you could be the
guy that that passes them the leaves
yeah they tell me what to do and I will
follow those they'll be like okay well
we're gonna go do this so what I need
you to do is collect dry wood so we
could have a fire later on that's yeah
see I'm the same way man like I like
doing those things but I don't know
sometimes I spend too much time on
something that doesn't make sense and in
like too little time and it's all
half-assed yeah like so if I'm building
or whatever like I might be like [ __ ] it
and I stop at halfway and I start like
sweeping the floor yeah no I know from
watching that show like the book the two
biggest thing is is fire and then
shelter yeah and then after that
securing fresh water hmm so that's
that's what you should do but for sure
the first thing I'm doing is fishing I'm
stranded all this stress is making me
hungry people have any fire to cook that
[ __ ] you dumbass I was like nope got it
and you have to do it before it hits
nighttime yeah you need to secure that
fire well it's gonna be cold
yeah secure the fire during the day
where's the hottest so and then you just
keep the fire going until it's nighttime
I want to learn how to [ __ ] rub two
sticks and make a
man dude I you know you know the guy the
primitive technology guy yeah I saw his
hands - it looks callous there calestous
[ __ ] yeah and that's how he does it with
his hands because I know even for me
like just shadowboxing on cement am i
both my feet blisters like a buck you
know we have baby hands and skin like as
adults so my buddy went to Costa Rica
right and then he was telling me like
there's a tribe out there and he was
looking at their feet and then he's like
all of their feet looked like dog pee
like it's black and there's like a thick
thick layer and they run around barefoot
and it doesn't hurt their feet and I did
research about like like primitive
humans back in a day or even today with
hunter-gatherers and when the British
first met Polynesians like they keep
writing about how strong these people
are like women will will swim across a
whole entire river like and with a with
a child on their back and then they
would go up and in a test like pinch
their skin and their like they have an
extra layer what they call it an extra
layer of skin and then they have thick
like calluses and stuff like that so I
think like what humans are supposed to
do is we're supposed to build like this
layer of strength because we're not
supposed to wear shoes yeah like that's
not natural right because I always
thought like man why are humans so weak
like if we didn't have clothes and if
we'd like how would we survive or like
how did they survive back then like our
shoes our feet so delicate we would walk
around in our like there's so many rocks
and yeah and and jagged little plants
like how the [ __ ] did we survive and it
was like oh if you have that thick
callous you could step on those [ __ ]
you know those spiky little balls and
nothing happens look at that photo I
showed you of that that indigenous like
that that should look disgusting dude if
that's what my fee has to look like to
be natural [ __ ] yeah it's definitely
because our feet are a kind of place
like if we put our hands out and we put
all our fingers together yeah that's
what our feet look like like now we're
like modern-day feet binding with your
shoes and [ __ ] yeah yeah and there's
very splayed out so it's meant to kind
of be very extremely
telling grab on the thing yeah so it's
more like our have want to spread out
where the opposable thumb is all the way
out and that's where their their uh
their will you call it the metatarsals
or what do you think they do climb trees
and [ __ ] all day I think what it is is
from what it looks like and how they
were standing when they was being
gripped is that there's there's no flat
surface in the Amazon yeah so when
they're going over rocks and trees and
stuff they're actually grabbing on to
these so it's almost like hands develop
the hand it's very uh primate like yeah
you know which makes me which kind of
creeped me out of it because even though
we here that are we're very similar to
two primates yeah like what looking at
those feet made me believe it even more
yeah and I even heard or not heard I
read that primates are actually going
into the Stone Age where they're
starting to use tools they're creating
tools to get around and rather evolving
dude it's so crazy it they found out
that they have a religion now what yeah
they believe in something and then
there's like a III didn't finish reading
the article but it's like they found a
chimp chimp group or something and then
they have like a belief system now it's
just so creepy dude I know that's so
[ __ ] critical planet of the apes man
they're gonna come attack us with
[ __ ] one day they're gonna talk yeah
I'm well we'll be dead by then our
children have to figure that [ __ ] out
I'll be [ __ ] dead and I'm okay with
it yeah oh well there we go man that was
quick that was super fast yo you know
every time we do this we have a topic
that we're supposed to talk about
so we're supposed to talk about what we
would do if we didn't have YouTube we'll
talk about that but did you know people
wanted us to talk about conspiracies
anyway oh really okay [ __ ] it then
yeah he kept saying I'll talk about
conspiracies okay well we did anyways
guys that's that wraps up this episode
of the genius brain podcast remember a
podcast about everything and anything
and we're just here to be along your
days where you're stuck in traffic or
you just want some homies to listen to
men this is the stuff that you hear
outside of the the typical stuff you see
online so uh yeah check us out on all
those audio platforms specifically
iTunes give us
five star and listen to us if you can't
see us on YouTube and right in those
comments below what you thought what you
want us to talk about your thoughts
about these conspiracy theories it's
very interactive don't just shut the
[ __ ] up and don't say anything I want I
want to hear you guys speak and go check
out what Amazon feet look like alright
so we'll see you guys next time remember
we are uploading on Thursdays and Sunday
so we'll see you then I love you sons of
[ __ ]
and we're out goodbye